morning during the latest january 6
hearing uh far more americans they were
googling gas prices than was searching
the web for january 6. here with more is
minority leader kevin mccarthy first of
all all right so this information comes
out about you and president trump and
things you said regarding this
and a lot of people thought that you
guys had had a split
and then all of a sudden you show up in
a meeting and apparently you guys are on
the same page again what happened
well look we have we have our
conversations all the time what's very
interesting to me is there is no split
between president trump and i we're
focused on one making sure this country
comes back to the policies that makes us
strong america first where we had low
gas prices we had a secure border we had
safe streets we had a future for kids to
be able to grow up in and the democrats
have now taken over they don't want to
talk about it you just showed that graph
why they have this january 6 meeting
here they are a january 6 hearing
overwhelmingly people are googling about
gas prices moody's had shown us that now
their families are spending 311 more
dollars per month that's paying for a
new car without getting the car 64 of
americans are driving to the
grocery store less because they can't
even afford the gas to get there and the
dems won't talk about it because they
have no solutions so what would
republicans do what would be different
if in november next january when the new
congress is in place and it's a
republican majority in the house and
let's say a republican majority in the
senate but joe biden is still president
what would be different
well the first thing we take over the
house we're going to make a commitment
to america we'll lay out exactly what
we'll do we'll make america energy
independent they'll make the gas prices
lower put more money into your pocket we
will secure the border the other thing
we'll do is we'll make sure your streets
are safe we're going to go into these
communities we'll provide them cop
grants only if their da's uphold every
single law we'll provide a parent's bill
of rights that you have a right to say
where your kids go to school and input
into your kids education that's just the
start of what we'll do
all right so you have been trying to
pressure rightly so and republicans have
been trying to get nancy pelosi to get
on the docket security for our supreme
court justices i cannot believe that
pelosi and schumer and the democrats
approve
of protesting in front of justice's
homes now we have amy coney barrett's
kids school being docs the location her
church is being doxed uh they give the
timeline of when she goes to church
this is more than harassment and
intimidation to me it's a clear and
present danger to every justice we saw
what happened with kavanagh why won't
nancy pelosi provide the security that
they deserve
that's a very good point because
remember this bill passed the senate 100
to zero and nancy pelosi has held this
bill for one month i've gone to the
floor three times to ask for unanimous
consent to bring the bill up to send it
to the president's desk we just saw an
individual travel from california the
only reason he was picked up and stopped
is because he saw security at the house
of justice kavanaugh had justice
kavanaugh not been there the security
wouldn't be there so his family his
spouse would not be safe and remember
why this is happening you had a white
house that said yes they should engage
going to those houses that's the
president's position you had chuck
schumer go to the supreme court and said
you're going to pay the price cavanaugh
and gorsuch this is what he said if i
did that one of these individuals you'd
be in jail i'd be accused of
insurrection and thrown in jail no doubt
there's always the attorney
the attorney general
goes after parents just for going to
school board meetings but nancy pelosi
holds this bill now the other thing the
american public has to understand what
the democrats want to do is change the
bill not to make it better but to send
it back to the house and delay it
they're doing everything they can and we
have you have a supreme court that is
making decisions
then they'll be held accountable those
people that are giving approval and
encouraging
the doxing the protesting the harassment
the intimidation they should be held
accountable uh kevin mccarthy thank you
for being with us hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else